welcome to this video tyrella from yum
yum that something Caribbean but I don't
know what it is this is actually Jamaica
okay yeah I knew that the colors are the
colors of the Jamaican flag but I wasn't
sure about the actual look of it okay
this guy is playing them Stonewall with
white and then normally the stone Ward
isn't such a great idea when it is still
possible to play md6 and t85 I played it
rather quickly okay let's hope I'm okay
I'm really okay just goes there and oh
I'm sorry yeah interesting do I get to
blockade reliably on e5 or not if I get
a reliable blockade on the square I
think I'm pretty okay but not easy to to
do maybe yeah no that's a good move
Knight coming to see form ok I'm going
to cover the d6 upon preparing ok is not
really reacting to the idea
hmm yeah so i can go Queenie 7yo keeping
keeping the blockade alive the night on
c8 is not the greatest piece ever but
maybe I really get it to come to the six
maybe I manage that Knight takes bishop
takes Bishop takes pawn takes and then
night comes to the six yeah that would
be would be quite nice man okay so he
doesn't object to that and yeah that is
some it's an interesting position here
it can easily become very nice for black
but not so it's not not so easy the
night on d6 is of course a great bloke
ADA but he's got the FR pressure so it's
not a very simple thing here for black
to play especially if you consider the
porn breaks that i have i have f 5 + f5
and known yeah let's say in an in an
endgame or so but in this in this middle
game type position it's not so easy to
to get in came so
John that's not much I can do him
f5 is a move possibly but okay can take
with the pawn pawn takes Bishop takes
and this is definitely okay for him Jim
it's difficult to do something a 6 B Phi
of him can be tried but it's not soon
not so easy to really open up the
queenside he can he has more space so we
can pretty simply switch switch between
the the flags
now I can I cannot do much it's nice
with this night on d6 but mostly mostly
black and just sit him yeah I mean white
white also has very little that he can
do but I was a bit optimistic when he
went for this for this some locating
situation here can really cannot do much
f5 it's not really going to work even
with you for coming f5 takes takes e4
this kind of thing
and it's kind of curious Queen takes you
five it's a somewhat strange move and
funniest thing is she's just continuing
like nothing ever happened yeah i'm just
going to invade here with with all
pieces it's a queen yeah before he gave
away em give away the queen i think it
was difficult to do anything really ok
6k let's let's enter with the Queen here
why are the kingside Queen g5 queen age
for this kind of thing check
yeah so how do you get the Queen in
there now quickly Queen a5 queen age for
one of those time morning that's really
loud white resigns yeah okay he's doing
that um ok so I just want to look at the
position i'm here when when he's not
blundering a Quincy five was really
strange so here I thought I thought
queen's eggs and I thought should be
okay yeah rugby one is stronger I think
yeah he I doubt that there's much going
on just sure this is about equal I don't
don't get favorable trades and hear that
make mine I'd be better he still as the
protector passer it is some it is fairly
equal an interesting moment was right
here I can play a five but really I
wanted to prepare it and not do it right
away maybe that's the right way to go
it's possible this is the idea where the
computer likes blacks chances wants to
play f6 yeah if white has to play f6
chat then I'm definitely in good shape
here this is what the computer wants to
do like a slightly better I am this is
Sir well at least right I mean here yeah
I can really try something the King can
possibly come up after Queen trade then
I've got a form and may probably silly
Robert now this this is kind of this is
the logical way to play I wanted to
prepare that get the King out of the g
file but then he was coming with
therefore it would be for f5s maybe
still an idea but ok TX I would have
taken with the Queen but after Queen
takes after after Queen takes there is
rook be one this is this is a really a
problem that would have been a very
unpleasant surprise it takes us right
iam I mean besides the fact that I had
at five earlier but this seems to be
right yeah it's not so easy for him to
attack see if I the second time with one
of the rooks and yeah I'm just I'm just
staying here it's very difficult for him
to do something without the bishop the
bishop on d3 is a just purely defensive
piece that cannot easily be used I mean
would be nice if he would get it to like
the e6 or something but that's not
really going to happen yeah so it made a
weird blunder with with the Queen takes
on c5 I mean blunder is wrong I mean
probably more slip or something alright
thanks for watching